Aerial archaeologists take to the skies over
remote wooded hills in central Norway.
An on board camera fires laser pulses at the
ground to produce a LiDAR image of what lies
hidden beneath the icy landscape.
This LIDAR image really reveals some
incredible structures on the ground here.
We're seeing all these strange formations,
circles and what look like three pointed
stars. The whole thing looks so weird.
It looks like something out of a cell
biology textbook.
The aerial image has uncovered dozens of
structures lost to history.
They're clearly man made.
And so that makes me wonder, how old are
these things and who made them and why?
Archaeologist David Hill is heading to the
site to investigate.
I'm very excited about the structures that
you can see on the LiDAR image.
Some of them I really can't explain.
I haven't seen them before.
Hill thinks some of the structures in the
image are longhouses.
Timber buildings built over 1000 years ago.
It suggests the mystery shapes are legacies
of the Norse warriors who rose from these
lands at the end of the eighth century ad.
I suspect they might be Vikings.
The thing that I'm really unsure about,
though, is the star shaped formation.
I honestly don't know what they are.
All right. We seem to be getting up to the
site.
According to the LiDAR data, deep beneath
this undulating land lies a vast array of
circles and stars.
Absolutely fantastic.
Many, many sites they've been altered, been
plowed over, but not here.
What we're seeing is intact.
Several of the circular structures are poking
through the earth.
More evidence.
Hill believes that this is a Viking site.
It seems to be quite a well defined.
Ditch. I think this is a burial mound.
Ditches were very important.
They delineate the sacred area within the
grave mound.
It's the realm of the dead outside.
It's the realm of the living.
So I'm now stepping into the realm of the
dead.
What we're seeing is a burial site from the
Viking period.
The image suggests this realm of the dead
contains the remains of over 100 Vikings.
You can see. One, two, three, four, five,
six.
I can't even count them.
This site is incredible.
Fiercely pagan, the Norsemen would often
cremate their dead in the belief that the
smoke would carry them to the afterlife.
For others, burial mounds are seen as
gateways to another world.
One inhabited by those who had died before
them and the gods they worshipped yet also
feared.
What these mounds represent is the cosmology
of the Vikings.
This is where the living would commune with
the ancestors and the gods.
Wow. Look at that.
Up there on the ridge.
Two carved slabs of granite crowned the
largest of the burial mounds.
This is an.
Enormous. Stone of this size would have been
certainly for somebody very important.
The Norsemen would often inscribe gravestones
like this with runes.
Mystical symbols which they believed were
originally discovered by the great God, Odin.
They could be used as a means of
communication between this world and the next
or as spells.
The stone was built to convene with the gods.
The spirit. Well, it was raised as a gift to
them.
According to Norse beliefs, half the warriors
killed in battle go to Valhalla.
The rest head to Folkvangr ruled over by the
goddess of sex and war.
Freya. And recent research suggests the
Vikings desire to appease their gods as they
prepare for these journeys has its origins
in a real historical event.
We've got a lot of tantalizing clues that at
the end of 535 ad, there was a massive famine
and millions of people died all across
Europe.
Geological records reveal that in that year,
dust from a massive volcanic eruption plunges
Europe into months of darkness.
Causing crops to fail and killing a third of
the entire population of Scandinavia.
All those natural phenomena that we today
understand by science.
Back in the Viking age, they would
understand by relating the gods to them.
As stories of this catastrophe are passed
down over generations, it inspires the tales
of destruction and vengeful gods that
dominate Viking myths and sagas.
In mythology, this is described as Ragnarok
or the Apocalypse.
And when that happens, things go dark and it
takes several hundred years for the
population to build back up.
What puzzles Hill is how the giant star
shapes in the image are connected to the
Vikings beliefs in their gods and the
afterlife.
This is without doubt the strangest thing
I've seen in archaeology.
I'm walking down one of the arms of the star
shaped structure.
Remarkable. Absolutely remarkable.
Hill knows that three was a magical number
for the Vikings.
The arms have to mean something.
Odin, the God who created the first humans,
was one of three brothers.
And before the Viking apocalypse.
Ragnarok. There were three winters without
summers.
What's more, the God.
Loki has three children.
Were three weapons.
And Fenrir, The monstrous Wolf of the
apocalypse, is bound by three chains.
This is clearly a link between the world in
which we live and the realm of the gods.
What went through the the minds of the
people who built this.